and never look
backs and simply learn to get ahead Jess
Danish a civil engineer turned data
scientist who decided to Simply learn
possible with a course from a premier
University career
Direction true champion who upskilled to
win
big how big a massive hike that
transformed my life Danish changed gears
pretty early in the race but pron wanted
to explore more to get ahead isar simply
learn from mechanical engineering to a
data analyst and a podcaster in his free
time transformation BR simply learn
industry expert
live or data expert
with a well structured course it felt
like a piece of cake that is simply
awesome what's also awesome is that
longer didn't choose a quick fix he just
added data science into the
mix nithan how did you change the game
worked on real industry problems to
become the real deal a joint family a
regular job responsibilities but nothing
could stop nin from getting ahead what
an allrounder de Hoya night with
flexible learning you can always make it
right passion
situation you too will find your way to
get ahead when you simply
learn simply learn get ahead with simply
[Music]
learn
let's let's chat and quickly Network
before we start it's a good way to
network right these events so uh we'll
be starting right on time uh thank you
for joining early thank you so
much
welcome everyone we'll be starting the
free program preview uh and uh we will
be starting right on time in few minutes
we just waiting for folks to get T in I
can see uh introductions coming in on
chat so I'm rashak Khan I'm your host of
today's webinar and I'm joining from
India tell us where you're joining us
from on chat here I can see folks have
started introducing themselves on chat
here I can see sha has joined from Kar I
can see Amber has join from Los Angeles
California and I can see then from
Canada would love to know in chat where
are you joining us from we'll be
starting in few minutes uh please get
settled in before we start just a quick
tip before we start that if you have any
question for our speaker here on M today
has already joined us uh you can put
down your questions in the Q&A box and
we will have a special dation for the
Q&A walk so in case you have any
questions uh due to related to the
program or in general career andl or any
anything related tol you can ask us
there in the Q&A box
and uh we'll take those questions uh
during this uh during the Q&A part of
the session which I'll be telling you
when we will be taking that in the next
slide uh but uh in case you have any
questions please make sure to put that
in the Q&A box not in the chat because
we get a lot of messages on chat and uh
we might miss out questions if you put
down on chat here so
awesome
okay I can see Lisa has joined from
Nashville I can see Shi from New York I
can see Dio from Brazil I can see Rama
from Chicago I can see zah has joined
from New York I can see Milan from us
awesome awesome I can see Vince has
joined from Atlanta
Georgia welcome everyone we're starting
the session in writing few minutes uh
please get settled in and would love to
know where I joining from on chart here
I can see a lot of introductions coming
in on chat I'm Rasha Khan I'm your host
for today's webinar and uh we'll be
starting the session in uh
sometime
awesome awesome keep the introductions
coming in we we can see an introduction
from our speaker here today with us Al
who has joined us we'll be taking us
through the program review of UT CIA
good camp I can see Amando has joined
from San San Diego California I can see
jungo has joined from Kigali I can see
Joseph has joined from D
Texas okay I can't I can someone has
joined from UK but I can get your name
from em ID please let us know your name
so I think before we start let's go
quickly go through the ground rules we
have here so as I said you can put down
your questions in the Q&A box if you
have a question for our speaker if you
put down your questions in the chat you
might miss it because we get a lot of
messages on chat and we would love to
answer your question and uh the session
is being recorded in case you want to go
through the recording of the session
again you can expect a followup email
with recording link webinar certificate
and bonus offer as well which you'll be
getting for attending this webinar for
the program which we have uh and also to
request a proof of attendance for this
webinar please enter your full name in
the post webinar survey which you would
want to see in the certificate of this
webinar now moving on uh this program is
powered by simply learn world's number
one online boot camp uh we are very
proud that we have 13 years of digital
digital skills training experience in
this field and also uh we have
professionally trained over 5 million
plus Professionals in over 150 plus
countries and we are very proud of that
so thank you so much for joining once
again uh now let's talk about agenda uh
we'll be we'll be obviously getting to
know a little bit more about you before
we start the session and we'll be
talking about AIML careers here we'll be
talking about what's a u boot camp and
we'll be sharing learner outcomes
enrollment steps of the program and also
a special duration for the Q&A part
we'll try to take a few as many
questions as possible during the session
as well and in case we are not able to
take up all the questions during the
session we'll try to take it in the Q&A
part of the uh session which will be
towards the end so please uh stay till
the end if you have a question also
folks who are asking about the webinar
certificate you will be getting the
webinar certificate you can basically uh
put on your full name in the the post
webinar survey for
that uh before we start as I said we'll
getting to know a little bit about you
uh so you can see a quick poll on your
screen right now uh let's get to know
each other a little better so you can
see a quick poll on your screen which
says that how many years of experience
do you currently have so quickly go and
vote uh for that quick poll which you
see on your screen so if you're
currently studying you can select the
first option if you have Zer to threes
of experience you can select the second
option if you have three to years of
experience you can select the third one
and the last one if you have more than
five years of experience I can see folks
have already started voting in uh their
answers here and folks who have just
joined right now we starting the session
and we'll be basically taking you
through the ERS boot camp review as well
in the session and talking about EML
careers before we start there's a quick
poll on the screen just to get to know
you a little better before we start so
how many years of experience do you have
currently I'll just give 10 seconds more
for the poll because I can see most of
the folks have already shared their uh
experiences on this
poll and I can see introduction still
coming in on chat awesome awesome that's
great I can see Bala has joined from
Campell I can see Shi has joined from
New York welcome welcome
everyone awesome I just I think most of
the folks have already shared uh their
answers on this quick poll so I'll end
the poll in 5 seconds so 5 4 3 2
1 let me quickly share the results also
with you folks so we can see most of the
folks more than half of the folks who
have joined us here have more than five
years of experience and I I can see that
1/4 of the folks have are currently
studying and few of the folks have Z to
three years of experience and few of the
folks have three to five years of exp so
thank you so much for sharing that with
us and uh moving on uh we have a speaker
here with us Amando Gana Amando would
you like to give us an
introduction sure absolutely rasa first
thank you very much for joining and
making time so I will be walking you
through what we what you would be
learning and the skills that you would
be acquiring throughout this boot camp
but first uh Rasha is my voice coming
through loud and clear yeah it is clear
for me uh I think folks please do let us
know in chat here if Armando's voice is
clear fantastic so Hey listen
um okay fantastic thank you Diego so
anyway I was uh telling that I will I'm
one of the actual trainers of these boot
camp and let me tell you something um
you know today there's a lot of thoughts
around data around making robotic proc
automation uh getting acquired new
skills and with all these data we have
nowadays there's not a better
opportunity to jump into data science
artificial intelligence which is by the
way the way I went into data science and
artificial intelligence I come from the
business so I was not a software
engineer I was not extremely technical I
was mainly doing data analysis analysis
in conj Superman programs I was a
director of
operations uh I used to I used to be a
program manager product line manager uh
I was leading a group of technical
account managers but in every single one
of my roles as you may already notice
there's a lot of use of dat
um data to make sure that you drive uh
informed decisions uh data to support
your decisions to prove something and
that's how I went into data science and
that was by the way 10 years ago imagine
10 10 years ago there was not even D
data science masters the amount of tools
and environments there were not were not
existent so I saw data science it was
kind of a manual process so I got into
data science I found my passion and I
found that it was able to help in so
many different areas manufacturing
Healthcare fraud detection uh human
resources and then all these tools come
about so with the experience that I had
between Cloud architectures experience
that I have with data analysis and all
the experience that I had in the
business supporting customers across
multiple Industries it just found
natural to me not to retain that
knowledge to myself but also to make
sure that it's shared because
today more than ever we need more data
scientists and even even if you look at
Linkin or other platforms there are
literally hundreds of thousands of open
positions around the world requesting
machine learning Engineers data
scientists AI product managers AI
engineers and there's just not enough
talented people there's a lot of people
taking some classes here and there but
people that has that have the skill to
apply that knowledge to real life
projects like real projects
manufacturing Human Resources that's not
aone so I'm here to uh make sure that
everything's very transparent very clear
and how the program is set up how the
platform looks like and most most
important what will you be learning okay
so thank you very much rashan thank you
so much for a great introduction uh
moving on we'll start with careers inl
machine learning uh so let's start with
how IML machine learning has extended
human capabilities so uh so can you take
us through that amount absolutely um so
uh now we have a boost in data so even
if you trace back through the beginning
of of the known history of humankind we
have been recording our information
within books or uh carbon Stone writing
paintings but there was not easy way to
share that information now the past 20
years with digital with digital
Transformations digital Technologies we
have been able to transfer information
back and forth in almost real time and
that has been a shift in the parttime on
how we humans connect with within
ourselves and how we do things look back
30 years ago 30 years ago we wouldn't be
having this conversation look we have
people from Canada from UK from Qatar
from the US from Brazil right now real
time interacting we wouldn't be able to
do that before but now this is what has
been changing the amount of data has
been exponentially increasing the
compute power has been increasing as
well and the cost have been decreasing
so now you can have a in a thumb draw
you can have terabytes of of data now
you look back in in 1950s uh you had a
million millions of dollars in in 5
megabytes storage so the fact that we
have been growing the amount of data we
can consume now that means that we need
to find patterns in that data you know
data records what we do every day
whether if it's project management how
we hire people how we make decisions
about budget now today we need to find
patterns and if we look back at all the
different revolutions we had the
Industrial Revolution remove the
physical load from the human right now
in this kind of Technology iCal
Revolution we're offloading some of the
mental burden of us humans and in order
for us to take up that mental burden we
need to find patterns to what we do and
then figure out how we can represent
those patterns in mathematical
representations that we can be in
applications in dashboards in reports
and that's precisely how data and
artificial intelligence is enhancing and
extending our our capabilities because
now we can find pattern to what we do do
and start replicating them without us
getting tired and by us having the
ability to make decision about other
things that require more context so we
need the more data the more the more
ground we'll have to find those patterns
and that's the reason why we're here in
in reality artificial intelligence is
not anything else but replicating human
intelligence or animal intelligence and
we have now very powerful machines or
very powerful tools to help us do that
when machine learning things that you
can't even run with your laptops so this
is part of what we're covering today and
again there's not a better time than
today to join this journey and to start
riding the way Raja totally agree with
that Amando uh moving on basically as we
can see that AIML has opened a lot of
career paths uh what are the career
paths folks can take up uh in this time
in um so and this is the thing that if
you can see all these roles are kind of
neat right look um there's a great
opportunity not only because right now
there's a wealth of opportunities for
everyone taking these classes I see that
even um there are people that are very
experienced like 75% of you have some
level of experience so you know that the
next step is to to give you a boost
right in way you drive decisions you
make recommendations even in your
participation maybe you want to shift
careers right but also around like 27 of
you are coming out from
school there a great opportunity so you
can land your first job as a data
scientist machine learning oper engineer
but here's the thing and here's the cool
part that you will notice that a lot of
these roles are brand new um a data
scientist s data scientist maybe those
roles happen to be maybe like eight 10
years ago so if someone asks I want a
data scientist with 15 years of
experience well good luck with that
because that was not a thing like 10
years ago go but even when you try to
set up all the infrastructure you can be
a machine learning engineer to set up
all the different Cloud environment or
on Prime environment to make sure that
you can process your data um
automatically that you can uh that you
can containerize your environments and
deploy them into operations as a machine
learning engineer or whether you want to
make sure that the data is properly
structured cleaned make sure you have a
good feature store for you to start and
business to start consuming data as a
data engineer maybe you are on the other
end you may be an architect or or an AI
product manager that will Define the
requirements and the technical
specifications that will combine both
the business problem with actual
technical artificial intelligence
solution or maybe what you want to do is
to actually create the models to create
the models that will find the patterns
that will be embedded in applications
whether you go on the infrastructure
side setting everything up making sure
that the data is already available that
you put together an AI solution or you
build your models these is your the tip
of this pier now there are other roles
like ai ethicist ai uh designer and a
lot of other roles coming up from all
these Revolution artificial intelligence
but trust me an AI architect was not
something like five years ago machine
learning up machine learning engineer
you look back five years ago that was
not a thing so you have now the
opportunity to get part of this tip of
this fear and start understanding all
those roles and broader your career path
because what you'll find in this boot
camp is a platform and from there you
will be able to make sound decisions
with the technical knowledge that you
need to start investing yourself in
other paths in your in your career okay
so very exciting times uh Russia
hopefully hopefully that addressed uh
that's great and also U now talking
about the skills you need to be up to
date you know skills to be AML
practitioner so do you really need all
these skills to become an AML
practitioner or you can start
somewhere well somewhat a f r that's a
great question you know um in a lot of
old boot camps you can see that they go
directly into supervised learning making
sure that they are libraries but
listen today to build a model is really
easy right you you don't need a boot
camp to create a model you don't need a
course to create a model there's very
simple very simple documentation to
create a model but creating a model
doesn't make data scientist just create
a model doesn't make an artificial
intelligence engineer as a data
scientist is not about the model itself
it's about understanding the data it's
about the storytelling it's about even
tweaking tweaking the algorithm to have
the best possible model so if we go back
and look what models are models are
nothing but mathematics on steroids
right mathematics with a lot of data so
if you want to make sure that's a data
scientist you're able to provide strong
objective evidence that what you are
doing makes sense for the business for
your stakeholders you need to figure out
a way to explain it and you need to
underline you need to understand the
underlying math behind that algorithm
not because everyone else understands it
because that's the reason why they are
hariring you as a data scientist because
you understand what others don't
understand and you will be able to
explain it in a simple way so do you
need statistics in maap yes you need
them there are some people that they say
that you don't but trust me as a data
scientist that has been leading teams of
data scientists send on machine learning
operations infrastructure talking a lot
of different stakeholders and
implementing Solutions it is mandatory
for every data scientist to have some
foundational mathematics like calculus
um
probability or stats
and um linear algebra so those are the
most so statistics calculus line algebra
you have a good understanding about
those three areas you're set then you
start building your algorithms right
mainly your models with algorithms and
th you have some learning methods right
most of them work with structure data
data that's in the form of rows and
columns and they'll be like the next
step which is the next step what you
will learn in this boot camp but then
most of the data is not instructive form
it's not in rows and columns most of
data is pictures is web articles it's uh
it's sound is it's microwave information
is um um um are collisions like in the
in the CERN right so you you have a data
a lot of data that is and most data is
not in the structor way so then you need
Advanced topics to figure out how to
make sense of all the data whether if
it's sound or speech or text or computer
vision or video or any sort of
unstructured data and that's when we go
into advanced topics like learning like
like deep learning and newal networks
for us to make sure that we understand
how to create a model that can predict
let's say if a if if if a if if if an
image is going to be showing up in the
screen like for example a dog or human
or maybe even so for us to build a very
powerful chat like large language models
right so yes all these skills are
required as a foundation to be a solid
data scientist or artificial
intelligence engineer
Russia awesome thank you for taking us
to that now moving on we have talked
about the skills we have talked about uh
basically what career paths you can take
up inl uh so what exactly is stopping
you from becoming an AIML practitioner
what is your biggest concern you can see
a quick poll on your screen here this is
a multiple choice question so you can
select multiple multiple options here so
uh you can quickly go and basically
share this what is your biggest concern
when it when it basically comes to
becoming an EML
practitioner and also we're getting a
lot of questions in the Q&A box so
that's great folks we'll be taking those
questions pretty soon in the Q&A part of
the session but we'll try to take as
many questions as possible for that as
well so don't worry about that so I'll
make sure your questions are answered so
in the meantime Russ while everyone
answers these I see very interesting
questions like what would be a typical
level position well that depends right
most likely will be a junior data
scientist a junior data scientist a data
analyst or a junior data engineer those
would be kind of the the entry-level
positions right um also I got
interesting question difference between
machine learning engineer data engineer
air developer air architect data
scientist the machine learning engineer
will set up the infrastructure that you
need to train and deploy your models
okay automatically that's a machine
learning engineer
uh they have solid um solid um skills on
the cloud architectures right they they
are focus more more on the machine
learning operations side okay that's a
machine learning engineer the data
engineer works on the only in the data
side starts aggregating all the
different resources combining them
making sure the data is consistent that
the data is clean and is ready to be
used whether by dashboards or by data
scientist or by all the different roles
that the
engineer the AI developer and the AI
architect the AI architect is the one
that works more on the product side
making sure that works with machine
learning operations engineer data
scientist to put together an AI solution
like an AI product let's say that I want
to put together an application that
predicts fraud so an AI architect would
say okay what are the components that we
need right then the other question I had
is is AI going to surpass human intell
elligence well that's that's still
subject to debate I think and better
said I believe it will uh sooner than
later I believe that it will start
happening after we make Quantum
Computing commercial uh because of some
fine-tuning um enhancements that we will
see but as a matter of fact it has
already surpassed human intelligence in
some aspects if you go to like uh Alpha
go uh it it already surpassed the best
go play in the world so I believe it's
going to happen I believe it's happening
but maybe not General artificial
intelligence but I think it will
okay can move forward um rash sure I
think uh thank you so much for taking
those question Amando I think we've
gotten a lot of responses here already
by folks basically what exactly is
stopping them so let me quickly end the
poll and share the
results uh as we can see that we have
gotten the highest amount of votes for I
basically can't find a program with a
fully comprehensive curriculum and I can
see less than half the folks have voted
for I wouldn't get the Practical
exposure you need to become job ready
and I can see a few of the folks have
voted for my Works won't allow me enough
time for Learning and very of the folks
have voted for I find it difficult to
learn from pre-recorded videoos so thank
you so much for sharing that what
exactly is biggest challenge and concern
when it comes to becoming an and
practitioner now talking about the
program here so we have this AIML
machine learning boot camp by UT which
Pro which provides comprehensive and
Industry aligned curriculum and also
give you access to Hands-On labs and
projects and also online virtual life
classroom experience as well uh this is
flexible to fit your lifestyle in case
you're working you're working
professional which I I see that we have
gotten here uh you know when we did the
experience pool as well the learning
format for this one is online and uh you
can complete this program in six months
you need to just give 10 to 15 per hour
weeks to complete this program uh so
arando just wanted to know like what
exactly happens in this live virtual
classroom what kind of experience you
know uh folks get when they join this
program can you tell us a little bit
about that yes absolutely so let me tell
you some of the B because I know the
rash mentioned some of them but one of
the best one of the
best uh benefits you will get of this
course is the networking site uh when
you jump into these into these boot
camps you will see that not only people
are um a lot of people are have senior
senior level in um in organizations and
they're looking for Boost to make sure
they can talk to teams or put an AI team
together uh but also there are people
looking to create Solutions or some some
of some people join um just looking to
create something new like can be
entrepreneurs or or start or begin
startup so the networking side is
amazing we have slack channels when
everyone interacts they interact with
myself they interact with with a
customer uh success uh uh manager they
interact with themselves
so uh initially what we do is an
induction section uh session where we
start you know introducing everyone
which is amazing also something that is
really beneficial is that the the the
overall this program was designed to
make sure that you don't only have the
theory but you have practical examples
look if you go to platforms to several
courses they will look at data like the
Titanic data set or classifi
flowers you know those data sets are
kind of cool to you know play with but
let's face it right you will be getting
data from manufacturing you will be
getting data from a school grades and
you will be getting text and you'll be
getting images so a lot of the a lot of
the examples I provided in most boot
camps and classes they are
hypothetical they have no direct
application to to any
industry however we focus on making sure
that everything that you learn has the
context of someone that is going to
apply these on a daily day-to-day basis
and that's the reason why the networking
is important because you bring us some
use cases we're studying something in
class which by the way you have some
pre-recorded videos because some people
they are good at self-learning so they
pre-recorded videos and then uh trainers
like myself we start going through the
concept
reinforcing what you IND the videoid and
applying them and doing Hands-On
exercises in class to make sure that the
concepts are clear for everyone but
here's the fun thing that you can
request some of us trainers hey hey you
know I have a I have these kind of
problem let's say um I need to do some
Market segmentation and I have no idea
how to do that using artificial
intelligence you can bring us your use
cases and we can cover them in class I
alongside with the with the
correspondent topics to resolve your
business problem that's a great
experience by the way so there's a lot
of practical lot of practical um um
experience the Capstone projects are
really real amazing they're really cool
um and also you have the flexibility to
jump in class and also to have yourself
learning so the overall learning
experience from what I from the feedback
I received and even as a as as a trainer
I love it because I learn a lot from all
of you because of all the diverse amount
of of use cases that you bring to a
table and all the very different
creative ways to solve them because
that's the other thing there's not a
single way to solve the same problem so
when when we start discussing about
potential alternative Solutions then
some of you start bringing better
Solutions maybe than the ones I have or
maybe than the ones we found so that
brings the experience very applicable
and that makes experience a tangible for
for Learners which again it's a it's
precisely the way that these boot can be
designed uh wow that that sounds pretty
interesting to me thank you so much for
taking us through the live virtual
craftroom experience I think we'll be
talking about the projects and even the
learning environment as well in the
upcoming slides now moving on at the end
of it all you get a UTS academic
Excellence boot camp certificate which
you can see on the screen here and core
and Electic courses certificates as well
a u Circle membership and a recognition
at an online convocation so in case uh
you want to invite your you know close
relatives friends family from far away
you can basically invite them to your
online communication which usually
doesn't happen in an offline setting
right you can invite everyone so that's
a pretty interesting thing about the
online convocation part uh now moving on
to the UT Dallas Advantage here so UT
Dallas uh is a renowned institution with
a rich history of academic Excellence
here uh basically you get sus on your CV
which is very highly respected and
acknowledge globally opening doors to a
diverse cul opportunities and network uh
Amando can you tell us how exactly the
UT do Advantage head folks who are
joining this
course yes absolutely so um first off
you will not be getting a diploma from
like any unknown unknown provider or
university um UT um at Dallas they
validate their curriculum okay with with
with the with their fellow
researchers uh with faculty members so
this is this is joined a joint effort
between simp learn and UT Dallas okay so
the curriculum is reviewed validated
make sure that it's in line with their
um their overall policies with the level
of quality because they are leveraging s
PL to represent a part of UT D and not
only that they are also so
um um there are also um again the
training material uh the the use cases
that have been that are constantly
constantly under review with again top
tier members of the AI community in UT
Dallas which makes it not only
beneficial to you because you end up
with a diploma that is recognized by UT
Dallas but you also acquire knowledge
and the skills that has been vetted on
both ends on the academic side with UT
Dallas with the latest research with
latest models with u latest applications
but also in the industry side with
trends like myself and there trends that
have the business experience so you have
the best of both worlds so and also as
you know UT Dallas is it's it's a it's
it's a global recognized University
right it's one of the top tier
universities um in in research and also
conet in artificial intelligence um in
likes of um of CCH and other
universities so great opportunity to
have again the mix between those two
worlds right the academic background and
the consistency and the foundation
backed by Duty Dallas and the business
experience led by uh by by tenure
trainers with the experience plaus and
their work inside so hopefully that uh I
is the question Russ that sounds pretty
interesting to me thank you so much AR
for taking us to the advantage of U now
talking about the eligibility and
prequisites uh in this you basically
need to have a prior experience in a
knowledge of mathematics and programming
a high school diploma or equivalent or
at least 18 years of age and uh you need
to basically have two or more years of
work experience which is preferred in
this case uh so just just a quick
question that U like uh basically having
a prior knowledge of mathematics and
programming have you seen students
succeed if they basically come from
maybe a similar background mathematics
or programming or even have a little
knowledge of mathematics and programming
what kind of uh knowledge are we
expecting here you know when we are
basically writing down that you know we
need these experience or knowledge in
mathematics and
programming um so it's it's it's not a
lot of knowledge because we'll be having
a refresher on math on statistics
calculus and algebra but at least High
School level so at least that you know
what is an equation what is the equation
of a line what is a
matrix um what is a little bit of
probability but again it you don't
require like an
inep tons of knowledge or or skills in
in math and programming also program
there will be a refresher but if you
know objectoriented programming doesn't
matter if it's python Java whatever um
it'll be very good now now of course we
will go again through refresh and
programming because we we we' known that
some of us we went to college or high
school like a few decades ago so maybe
you don't have all the concepts fresh
your mind so we'll do a refresher so you
can gain that knowledge back and also in
terms of programming uh just as long as
we can you will not be programmed you
will not be software developers but you
need to make sure that your code is
efficient so that you can uh
you can train models you can process
data in a way that is automatic and it's
a way that it's efficient it's a way
it's effective and a way that others can
can um con can learn from and in a way
that you can transfer your code to
someone else whether to a machine
learning uh operations engineer or an AI
product manager so that your code can be
transferable and understandable and
that's what we'll be
covering wow that's great thank you so
much br answering that now moving on how
this program prepares you uh how the
program builds your em skills step by
step I wonder can you take us through
these steps absolutely so there will be
one first session that'll be orientation
so you get familiar with the platform
you get familiar with all the tools
you'll be using and all resources which
by the way there are a lot of resources
that you have you'll have available uh
so the first part is okay what is the
ecosystem how does the ecosystem look
like different roles that will be
available for you uh between ebooks and
presentations and humans like myself
right and um you learning platforms so
it's all the ecosystem and also
introductions how we will be
communicating over slack and the types
of questions you'll be addressing and
how we can be communicating with each
other right so that's the first part
then introduction on to artificial
intelligence there are several questions
more lower level questions like specific
difference between data science machine
learning for example right and the
relationship between data science
machine learning and artificial
intelligence and deploying so we'll get
a little bit more into the Weeds about
what is specifically data science what
is artificial intelligence what are some
use cases and also how to start thinking
of problems as artificial intelligence
problems right so that's the second
layer then we'll get more technical into
data science with pipon okay now by the
way between uh introduction and
orientation there will be a some
refresher Mapp and programming so that
by the time you get into apply data
science you have the skills to import
different types of data and start doing
some exploratory data analysis to
understand some data we'll be covering
uh distributions
correlations um uh we'll covering things
like how to calculate P values uh what
is a p test for Kai Square uh to make
sure that you understand how data
science with python can help you drive
insights and get into modeling now then
we'll cover in machine learning there
will be specific algorithms that will
help you to solve very specific and
unique problems that you can solve so
with a data science and understanding
the data with the with the foundation in
Python now we take a DI into the
algorithms that we TR
that will train that will be trained and
will produce a model will produce a
mathematical repr presentation all the
patterns then we'll get into a little
bit more advanced topics so before that
machine learning and Below it's mainly
structure data rows and columns like
Excel spreadsheets on or SQL tables but
then we'll start processing more complex
data like images and videos and sound
and that's when we get into deep
learning specifically with caras now
there are different different Frameworks
uh including pytorch torch and others
and we will cover them lightly but the
most widely used library for deep
learning is caras and that's the one
we're focusing on then we'll get a
little bit into uh geni um how llms the
architecture of an llm and these be
mainly how to do prompting engineer how
to interact with different with
different gpts and at the very end
you'll be having the opportunity to
participate in Capstone projects like
the projects that will be stacking all
over the knowledge and the skill that
you have Acquired and apply it to
specific business
problem and also on the side we have
electives I'll be a bit more advanced
and Rasha can speak to them yeah so
thank you so much for taking us to the
steps arando about the electives the
electives in this program are basically
optional and you don't have to pay
anything extra for that so electives
here are ADV Advanced deep learning and
Machine Vision NLP and spe recognition
reinforcement learning UT a bootan
master classes so you don't have to pay
anything extra for that these are
options if you want to take it up we
won't be charging anything extra for
that uh moving on to the tools and
platforms you'll be learning in this
program as you can see python Django
kasas open CV M lib uh flask tensor flow
you know being one of the tools which
are present on the screen and there are
many more tools and platforms we cover
in this uh program uh maybe can you tell
us a little bit about few tools and
platforms which basically folks will be
covering this program to just give them
a better understanding about it yes
absolutely so by the way the the overall
AI ecosystem is so Broad and so vast
that it's very easy to get confused with
the amount of libraries and tools that
are at hand uh the ones that will be
covering in these boot camp are the ones
that will be giving you the flexib
ability to customize your own
environment right I mean there are some
automated tools that you know they're
kind of cool but what you what you will
learn is everything that you need to
build your models for grounds up so
definitely python will be touching base
on um some libraries for visualization
like map live and Seaborn I we'll be
discussing libraries for General machine
learning or classical machine learning
like I could learn we'll be also
reviewing libraries for computer vision
like open CV for a natural language
understanding and processing like nltk
and caras for scientific processing like
scipi and some Frameworks that can help
to deploy your models like Jango or
flask now there are indeed a lot more
but the ones you will cover will be the
ones first the ones that have more
stable the ones are backed up by by
industry by research by Academia and the
on that will help you to build flexible
products okay the most flexible products
and the ones that almost every tenard
data scientist and Eng engineer knows
about so this is some of the lar covered
but as russan mentioned this may be
covering a few more that will add up to
the toolkit that you will require to be
a senior and a tenure data
scientist thank you so much Amanda for
taking us the tools and platforms moving
on the Capstone projects we have talked
about for Capstone project you can
showcase to your future employers uh now
having a Capstone project in your CV
basically will give a true experience
when you're going and trying to get a
job you're trying to get job ready there
uh there are many more industry aligned
projects for your portfolio you can add
here as you can see on your screen uh so
AMU like how exactly having these
projects on your portfolio coming from a
completely different background uh going
and trying to get a job inl field how
does this help you know how does how
does this help showing that real
experience which you don't have
right absolutely Raj so as as I
mentioned earlier a lot of trainings
boot camps and online courses they use
dummy they use dummy data sets not
industry related data sets across
multiple Industries so by the time you
come out from all these uh course and
training
classes uh you'll be very good with
dummy dummy data sets but when you start
facing like real world problems you no
idea how to tackle them so we're trying
to do is to get data sets like real data
sets from real companies solving real
problems and try to address as many
possible Industries as possible to have
diverse types of problems to solve from
creating a model that can predict
attration to a model that that can that
can give you insights about like video
training classes like how to diagnose
cancer or how to process images right so
we try to give us as many diverse type
of problems across multiple Industries
so by the time that that that alln is
graduate at least they know what they
would be facing so that's that that's
how we align our projects to
Industry problems and with real data
from real
companies uh that sounds pretty
interesting thank you so much for taking
us through that now moving on to the
learning environment I think someone on
the chat has asked about the cap project
slide once again so I'll just quickly
share it I think butth you basically
will be covering the Capstone project
part in the learning environment as well
right a little bit about that so I think
uh we will be taking up that during the
learning environment uh for someone who
has asked uh on chat here so uh would
you share your screen for taking us
through the learning environment
on sure absolutely
um let me share my screen sure meanwhile
you do that uh folks we have gotten
pretty interesting questions on the Q&A
box here and we'll be taking those
questions pretty quickly uh maybe like
during the session or during the Q&A
part so uh please have patience and stay
till the end of the session for that and
also folks who basically are asking
questions about uh basically the program
part as well we'll be taking those
questions as well so please don't worry
about will make sure all of your
questions are answered before that let's
let's take you through the learning
environment for you to have a better
idea exactly what goes around in this
program by you this a boot camp
absolutely and apologies I've been
presenting okay so this how the learning
environment looks like so first you will
see that you have your UT andas mchine
Lear boot camp when you go to the
program you will have all the different
sections right and also a way to mark
your progress okay with all the
requirements
in the main tab so by the way you even
have a way to add to your calendar all
the different live sessions so it
integrates with Google and other
calendars like I call and other
calendars which makes it very very
convenient
right then you'll also have a series of
resources uh slack channels uh but then
when you go into each of those section
by the way every section is very similar
okay very similar so in in the format so
let me explain what you will find in
every one of those
sections so the first thing you will
find is um all your surf learning and
the self- learning are all the series of
videos that you can watch um now what
you shareed the videos and what you
cover in the live classes is somewhat
similar somewhat similar it's not
identical but what I try to do is to
make it more applicable to Industry
right but you will find also all the
theory over here here with all the
lessons again all this is
self-paced then you have your live class
agenda right all the different classes
you have and here you will find
recordings so you will find all the
different recordings of all the previous
sessions which is super cool right I
think the recordings are uploaded like
24 or 48 hours after the session when if
you skip a session for a reason you can
always go back to the recording analyze
if you have questions or slack and we
can have conversations over slack then
you'll have the assessment so for every
assessment you you will see that you
have a like a test where you have 25
questions and you'll have to pass them
but then you have problems look at these
one of the problems is for an HR
department you want to make sure that
you are able to suggest retention
strategies again this is marketing but
there are there are other problems and
for every lesson you will have to submit
one solution one for not for both
problems just for one but the problem is
very clear describe you have the
objective and you have you know all your
different data sets
dictionaries not only that if you go
back to self learning here you'll have
here your reference mat you have your
data sets all the slides that you find
in the self learning the slides that I
go over as a trainer you will find them
here in ebooks so there's no content
that will take you by surprise you can
download all your content beforehand
review it and then come to class with
questions and also you have your
notebooks will be working in Jupiter
notebooks well it can be Jupiter lab or
jupyter notebooks but we'll be creating
Jupiter notebooks you can find the
templates over here okay now then some
of you may be wondering okay so how do I
how do I practice where do I code so we
give you an alternative so so that you
don't have to install anything in your
computers you have the ability to use
Simple learns lab simple learns lab
there will will set up a virtual machine
a virtual environment just for you not
share this is just for you when you can
upload uh upload problem now here with
my network but normally you'll have your
uh your lab here then the very end you
have your cstom project now some of the
ctom
project um right now we we're adding
some of them in the in the castom
projects but normally the projects
are computer vision natural language
understanding some of them are
Healthcare like genome expression
pattern recognition and stuff like that
so this is how the learning uh platform
looks like and of course you will have
here the option to figure out how far
are you from um from obtaining your
certificate so again very comprehensive
platform very easy to navigate very
intuitive and
blends virtual self-paced with virtual
instructor lead with projects with
exercises by the way in inside all your
self-pay you will find exercises for you
to answer on your own and then come with
questions to class so that's that's how
the platform is it up Raja hopefully uh
the explanation was clear enough so that
there are no no questions from our
audience thank you so much Amando for us
to the learning environment uh let me
just quickly share by back my screen
here also folks do let us know if you
have any questions about the learning
environment of H in BO camp on the Q&A
box here we'll be taking the Q&A box
questions PR so let me just quickly
share my screen
back awesome now moving on uh so we'll
be talking about the learner outcomes
here so the good thing is we have
learner outcomes uh coming from uh you
know uh from worldclass organizations
and diverse Industries they come from
Industries like it software product
manufacturing Pharma Healthcare BFS and
others and they also come from companies
like sap coid well farago Target seens
infosis HP IBM and many more like this
uh and moving on basically s also
provides you uh career assess Services
as well to help you with your job search
uh in this what we offer is you get free
access to expert webinars and also you
get to learn on real world projects
across Industries and also we'll be
providing you job assist Services as
well which we have partnered with Talent
Inc in this you get access to job portal
uh resume rabbit and also resume review
and reite service from top resuming and
also one-on-one interview of service
from Top interview so moving on uh the
program fee for this particular program
is
$88,000 and uh we have financing options
also available for as low as $14 per
month uh if you have any more questions
you can always reach out to us as ask us
at s.net I'll be sharing that email ID
on the chat in sometime uh so we have
talked about basically the skills we
talked about what the program covers so
what exactly is stopping you from taking
this program so would you like to be
enroll into this aail boot camp by utls
you can see a quick poll on your screen
here and uh it's a very quick poll on
your screen to let us know your
interests toward enrollment to the util
boot cam
okay yeah yeah please please we can
answer some of the questions here
because I know we're running out of time
I have questions from uh Diego asking
about the more advanced topics like what
is greater market today whether if it's
a process Imaging spech and audio look
uh something that I've noticed Diego is
that it comes by waves so at some point
there's a big F on image processing for
like six months or maybe a year and then
things shift and then becomes natural
language processing with large language
models and then again with video
processing and then speech so I would
say that I have not seen a consistently
predominant area I think it comes by
waves again right now the f is about
llms right but at some point everyone
will know about llms and then something
else is come through something else so
right now it's kind of generative
artificial intelligence but what I
believe is going to happen is when you
have a mix of several of them okay um
and also something you can do is you can
go to LinkedIn and then actually start
looking in LinkedIn to see the the
keywords for some of them also another
question I got very good question there
thank you another question from Tom is
about hey I live in a small town um so
what's my best approach should I
approach local businesses or do remote
jobs today we'll live in the a
hyperconnected world so the world is
your oyster right so you can apply there
a lot of remote works a lot of remote
jobs that require data scientist to be
quite honest as a dantist you don't
require to be at the office so you will
find an assortment of positions related
to data science analytics are remote so
it really depends for you if you want to
boost
now
okay I think uh our basically speaker is
facing some technical issues he'll be
right back in few seconds meanwhile I
can see a lot of you folks have already
shared your enrollment towards the UT
boot camp and I think someone has asked
about uh the fee part as well of of the
financing options so let me just clear
that on the chart here so it is $74 per
month I'll just be sharing that on chart
here for to help you out with your query
here and I'll be quickly ending the poll
in 5 seconds so basically let us know
folks if you are interested in enrolling
into the UT delas aail boot camp you can
see a quick poll on your screen here and
I'll be ending this poll in 5 seconds so
five 4 3 2 1 thank you so much for
sharing uh your interest towards the
enrollment of the program now moving on
I think folks were asking about the
enrollment steps and the induction uh of
this particular program when exactly
stop stopping uh starting so enrollment
and the free schedule for program
schedule for this particular program is
basically starting from uh January 8th
uh to 2024 and the class will be
starting from see like 8th of January
2024 and uh there are very simple three
easy steps you need to follow you need
to submit an application to us at
ask.net I'll be sharing that email ID on
chat here and then once you have
submitted your application your
application will be going for a review
and based on the review you'll be
getting admissions call from Simply lar
learning consultant uh so also just to
let you know we have very limited seats
for coh we only take folks like from 25
to 30 folks per coh in order to make
sure they're getting all the attention
that is required uh when you're joining
this program also um for folks who have
already shared their interest through
enrollment uh this this is a quick pull
through just to understand how soon do
you plan to enroll into the UT boot cam
can see a quick pull on your screen and
there are four quick options here if
you're planning to join immediately you
can select the first option within 3
months uh second option within 6 months
third option and the last one more than
6 months from now uh for attending this
webinar you'll be getting a bonus offer
uh for basically uh joining this program
and we'll be sharing you that bonus
offer over mail post webinar and uh so
basically you can opt out for the bonus
offer as well if you are attending this
webinar for this particular program
preview you have shared your interest
towards enrollment so that's great and
and also for folks who are still
thinking about it uh basically when to
join uh you can select the options
within 6 months or 6 months from now
because why to lose out on the bonus
offer right getting for attending this
webinar for udl boot camp I can see most
of the folks have already shared when do
they plan to Endor but I'll just give
five seconds more uh for before we enter
pool and we have a speaker back here
with us uh so welcome back Amando I
think you were facing some technical
issues
yeah Zoom kicked me out so my apologies
for that no worries no worries uh I
think we just give five seconds for the
poll because I think most of the folks
have already shared when do they plan to
enroll uh so 5 4 3 2 1 let me quickly
end the poll thank you so much for
sharing that with us now moving on to
the Q&A part I think we just have few
minutes left I think we can just take
five minutes to quickly address few
queries I think you have answered most
of the questions right uh maybe let's
just browse through the question
questions here in the C box and uh take
up questions you know which are
pending yeah so I I don't see any of
questions but I would like to wrap it up
with a quick comment Raja and you know
and maybe Raja will kill me for these
for saying these but whether it fits
with us or someone else really delve
into Ai and data sign Mach learning I we
wish that it will be with us because we
have worked really hard to make sure
that everything's applicable but trust
me once you get your foot into data
science and get a good grasp you will
see what no one else is able to see you
will be able to find patterns with no
one else's patterns you will be able to
understand data in ways that no one else
can understand and that is such a
fascinating Journey um again I I I've
seen people's lives change and then you
have the opportunity to change other
people's lives with your models with
your patterns with your insights so
again with if f with all someone else
just de with it start looking at it get
into data science again ideally will be
with us because we would work hard to
make sure you get the skills that you
need with all the the opportunities you
can expand your perspective but once you
get a foot into this out say it's you
will hardly go back right it's really
really fascinating and you'll see all
the advancements and you will be able to
understand a lot of the a lot of the
lingo with large language models and gen
and processing and Cloud infrastructure
things that most people don't understand
but now you will okay so right that
that's all for me I don't know if you
have anything else thank you so much
Amando uh thank you so much for taking
us to the program preview of UTS ml boot
camp uh we will just end this basically
session with a quick survey question
which we have uh before we end thank you
so much for joining us thank you so much
uh for sharing a lot of tips for you
know folks who have basically raised a
lot of queries when it comes to AML
thank you so much thank you for your
time thank you uh so folks before we end
the session we just have a quick Poll
for you to understand if you need
assistance into enrolling to the program
uh I would highly recommend folks who
have already shared their interest
towards enrollment and also have let us
know when do they plan to enroll as well
uh please do quickly just share
basically if you need assistance into
enroll into the program you can see a
quick on your screen with two options
yes or no uh please choose an option
which is the most suitable for you uh
before we end this session and also uh
please don't leave uh yet just yet
because I have a quick survey question
for you here uh to understand what
exactly are you expecting from our
webinars because we're trying to
implement a lot of new categories of
webinars to help you out to add any
value when you're attending this webinar
here so I just have a quick two seconds
you surve question after this uh just
basically understand what exactly is the
expectation here
thank you so much for sharing uh
basically if you need assistance inter
enrollment I'll be quickly ending the
poll here uh now moving on uh so thank
you so much arand once again for joining
us uh would you like to say something to
the audience before you
leave yep just uh please take a
dive really it's passionate topic and
I'm hoping to see you in our next
cohort awesome uh we are getting a lot
of appreciation for you by the way on
the chat here so I can see Anthony has
said I'm you're super great and you're
amazing thank you so much and Bala has
said thank you for for the excellent
introduction about this program uh I
think you're mute uh if you're speaking
amand uh and
uh okay okay okay I think uh someone has
also said shahul has said basically
thank you mrandu and great coordination
appreciate that appreciate that we were
able to you know showcase a great
condation here and also a great program
review walk through by Amando here uh so
thank you so much Amando once again for
joining in I just have a quick quick
poll question here quick survey just to
understand what exactly you folks are
looking for uh when basically uh it
comes to our future webinars here so
what topics or areas of Interest would
you like to see covered in our future
webinars here I've launched the quick
poll here survey quick poll question
here so you can see like there are many
options here you can choose from but
there is one option here where basically
if you don't don't find your basically
suggestion here on this poll you can put
down your suggestion on the chat here
I'll make a note of it so don't worry
about that yeah that's fine and also
coming you know to sah yeah of course
we're inviting you but hopefully in this
webinar you'll learn what the skills are
required like statistics uh calculus
linear algebra all the libraries that we
went through I mean you can also
research them on on your own and put
something together so hopefully at least
this let you know what the r roles
available uh what are the options
available and what's the difference
between different roles and also the
skills you require in case you want to
pursue this on your own so uh hopefully
you you you learn something something
new which was the main
intention yeah uh I can see most of the
folks have already shared what exactly
is their expectation uh what topics or
areas of Interest would you like to see
covered in the future webinar I'll just
give five seconds more uh folks who
couldn't find an option on this
particular question poll here you can
share that on the chat here I make a
note of it if you have a suggestion for
our future webinars and I'll just
quickly end this poll in 5 seconds so 5
4 3 2
1 okay let me quickly end the poll and
just quickly share it as well so I can
see a lot of folks have voted for career
advancement strategy so that's great I
we will make a note of it and we'll try
to bring up more future webinars on that
we do a lot of webinars uh like on
Career master class as well but we'll do
on Career Advan advancement strategies
as well uh I can see 50% of the folks
have voted for uh three options which
have gotten equalent votes resume
enhancement review and tips tools
platforms Library workshops again that
will something we would love to uh you
know bring it in and personal branding
networking that is equally important I I
I totally agree with that and I can see
38% of the folks have also voted for
program project demos as well and a few
of the folks have voted for case studies
and Trends Trends industry specific
invites I can see how the folks have
voted for that this is something
upcoming in November and December so you
can expect a lot of these Trends uh
industry specific insights being covered
so thank you so much for sharing with us
what exactly are the topics or areas of
interest you would like to see covered
in the future webinar thank you so much
everyone for helping us out uh to make
this webinars you know better every time
we do it and again like once again thank
you so much arando for joining us and
taking us to the program to we'll be
ending the session now thank you folks
for joining in thank you thank you so
much thank you
everyone uh I think someone has asked
about the email uh so if you have any
questions about the program you can mail
us at ask us at simply learn.net I'm
just putting that on chat here you can
just mail US mail us here and uh
basically if you have any questions
about the program in general uh and
basically we'll be answering all of your
queries from here so please do that if
you have any more questions about the
program thank you so much thank you for
joining thank you for being a great
audience thank you so
much
that